let's roll here sicilian i have three ok
open Sicilian and okay well usually it
is Knight f6 a6 what do you do in your
own games when you're seeing something
that's not so typical here's one thing
you could be thinking about what are the
differences what is what is this move
well what does this move this typical
move do that this move does not there's
no pressure on this pond so what it
means is I have the time for first c4 to
reinforce my grip over d5 and only then
follow up with Knight c3 you catch that
it's a good line of thought to run with
looking for the differences between the
typical move and the atypical move this
is typical this is a typical at this
moment this moment right here on this
particular move so what does this really
mean does it mean my opponents losing no
um what it does mean with this last move
though is that this is a weak point I'm
going to play here because I want my
night to eventually pivot on e3 and then
jump into that weak point just want to
get more development in Knight c3 let's
go I'd have to worry about any silly pin
either
all right um okay there's um what's the
story here what's the clean up to I
think she's setting herself up for bad
things she's getting herself in trouble
here I think I do something as commas
developed Bishop e2 what should I be
fearing f2 this move stops Knight g4 any
thoughts about the queen is really in a
bad spot because AI could be doing moves
like Bishop e3 at some point I could be
jumping into d5 with tempo let's just
castle first I could be playing the g5
removed this night and then all the more
appealing night d5 so a lot of talk here
what's the scoop here who stands better
who has a better structure white this is
not good there is a setup that is good
but I mean not in this order not with
the Queen comin out it's more of if
you're going to have this structure 5d6
you want the bishop to be posted on e6
to watch over that weak point this is
like a night off but with c4 included
it's kind of tough it's restricting b5
and d5 where how does black untangle
here pawn push to be three and then just
play my bishop out chopping night throw
a night in here I like my life on my
dark square Bishop though
let's just do this there's no there's no
rush this night is unprotected actually
why did I run with this 93 move yeah
maybe I could have done without be three
alrighty then whenever I say alrighty
then I think about you know JC knows
what I'm talking about JC what is he
talking about Bishop here or night here
get right here I like Bishop here yeah
no no no no no yeah we're gonna have a
change of structure coming up yes
Fineman Drac got it mr. jim carrey my d5
chop how do I recapture I'm I'm tree I
have a space advantage here and I'm
gonna have this night right here hitting
this night and he's he's gonna have to
run home is he too good for his home
there's another one for you f4 is a
follow-up if this pond is not around
this night starts to lick his chops at
the d4 square where did you go from
there I honestly don't know but it's a
plan f4 is to try and just remove this
pond it's try and open up the F file my
opponent it's just to open up actually
there's several ways you could view or
several reasons behind wanting to run
with the move like f4 could it look at
all the benefits of it open files or
opponents on Castle removal this pond to
have d4 available so what does this
translate into let's take first let's
open stuff up and pawn takes I just
recapture my bishop and then pond pushes
hitting at f7 is probably good good to a
good to do
better words there what about trade some
light squared Bishop soph know you want
to lose pieces no I could do that Bishop
takes Queen takes my queen is here to
defend this pond laterally this night is
having a bad day I think right he can't
be too uh can't be too excited about
things candy is he saying i love h day
seven right now he's boxed out for as
long as i keep these guys as is he's a
he's a dead duck there on the edge the
old rim is dim trick not trick adage
Bishop takes Queen takes ok now the
ponds get rolling connected passed pawns
that was the other deal right here space
space this might not ever have a home
now if I go here you will so i won't go
here but i just reinforced stuff pawn
push right here I want to keep these I
just want them to sit
stay right there anybody here that hog
in the background okay well cuz well
there's no night there's no tricks with
this either cuz I'm my queen defended
enough yes she talk i'll set it right
motorcycle dude hi bishop here if i go
here then there's a five I don't even
want to allow that file to open up just
play here let's trade a little bit this
Bishop is kind of well I'm also doing it
somebody I can jump into f5 if he gets
here bad stuff happens quick and my
Knights also in the spot now to watch
over this trouble look here boom okay
now what I think I just shoo this night
away god they're night tricky stuff
around the corner whoa counter-attack
doesn't work I have my night defended
their an awesome time pressure here time
travel time type of time trouble time
made on g7 get that Queen out of there
okay blunders happens no time no time
kitchen sink variation kitchen sink no
time alright good game BB 13 let's go
back back let's flip flip where is there
an improvement right here put on the
brakes right here you have to stop that
a 6 move i'm pretty sure because the
move order does matter you don't want me
to get in this c5 move prior to
developing my Knight to c3 so what I'm
getting at is just go with this first
Knight f6 Knight c3 and only then a six
and then you're in a night
hi if you do a six first and I get c4 in
you get into a not so good night off
right and this this is I don't know I
can't you really have to know what
you're doing went with this particular
structure and I'm not so sure I I could
agree with going with this setup right
here if you are going to go for it let's
just say it is for some reason still
good this eventual bishop moves should
be to eat six to watch over that week
square but you ended up playing to d7
and I mean another organization it with
this structure with this d65 structure
you'll want to have your king already
had your king your king knight on f6
your butt your Queen Bishop on e6 and
your queen night on d7 all either
directly or indirectly influence the d5
square which is a key square in this
position without a doubt your night
directly your king night directly
watches over this your bishop directly
watches over this in your queen night
I'm saying indirectly because if there's
ever a Bishop g5 move and Bishop takes
Knight the Queen night can recapture and
then be in a position to replace your
king night with watching over d5 I can't
move the pieces otherwise I would it
would be a little bit clearer but anyhow
I can't recommend a five and switch this
move order move order up go with this
night out immediately and then if you
want to play a six-play six all right I
think that's my main suggestion and main
suggestions are often coming about with
regard to a particular pond advance and
that's what we're seeing a six move when
it was played in a 5 to follow okay
let's close out